it's my first time at the end 500 I've
done a lot of amazing things in my life
but this is definitely right up there
that's incredible and it's just you
fueled the tradition
please hey you go just lower yourself
slip that leg in oh my gosh hi go ahead
this is like claustrophobic you're about
the only one that would fit in my car go
in your shoulders and you get all the
way in here all the way all the way
there you go this is horrible yeah you
know I couldn't noway from four hours
ago panic Ebru two minutes in the garage
I don't know how they do that I truly
don't know how I don't even know how you
could possibly be in control of that car
I was so terrified no you have to be so
athletic to be able to handle that that
g-force that's incredible
my god I I couldn't breathe I got
nauseous I couldn't feel my legs
they out of the car and I was like way
out again around a road course then
she's really she'd really throw up then
dude how do you do this before Howard
how do you do this before some people
ask how you work out for four hours but
it's just what I do for four hours I got
out of that car and I was like I can't
believe she's not strong I cannot
believe it I cannot believe it
and when I got out of that car all I
could think about was I can't believe it
Danica I can do that before hours this
is me off because I thought for sure
that I would be able to take her if it
ever came down to it but not so much
anymore I mean that's incredible it's
truly an incredible feat of strength